here with more judicial watch president
tom Fitton Tom to me this is a
breakthrough we've been asking the
question how high up we know that the
deep state actors are now turning on
each other
page struck are pointing the finger at
then Attorney General Loretta Lynch and
we've got of course James Baker saying I
knew from the beginning this was a bad
idea
then of course you got the deputy FBI
director McCabe saying we wouldn't have
got a FISA warrant without the dossier
the dirty dossier the unverifiable
dossier then you have Brennan and
clapper hating Comey and come--and
McCabe going at each other so I would
assume between all that infighting and
all the finger-pointing and the what is
now a civil war and circular firing
squad I think we're going to get to the
truth finally well certainly now we need
to expand the investigation to the Obama
State Department Jonathan Winer who was
close to Christopher steel the Russia I
mean to Libya expert for John Kerry
State Department was shepherding steel
and used and actually helping him write
the dossier or a part of it that was
laundered into the FBI in Justice
Department the steel dossier was written
in part according to Winer he wrote
admitted this in the op-ed in the
Washington Post he admitted he helped
write a summary of other material he was
getting from the Clinton gang and then
laundered it through steel to the DOJ
and FBI these new emails show that he
was in communication with Victoria
Nuland and they wanted to meet in New
York about the Russian matter we were
suing for Russia Gate documents related
to steel so we know it's about that and
this meeting took place almost
simultaneously with a meeting that Glenn
Simpson had with the State Department
about Russia gate as well
remember Victoria Nuland had blessed the
meetings between the FBI and Christopher
Steele in in the UK in the summer of
2016 and then other documents showed
that she was working with Steny Hoyer x'
office to get this Russian material
through and then pushing classified
information to make Trump look bad just
before the inauguration the State
Department is at the center of the storm
in terms of the
of the obama administration against then
candidate Trump and then the incoming
president mr. Trump so we know this we
know that Bruce or and Kathleen Cadillac
all warned about the dossier bought and
paid for an unverifiable steals agenda
before the first FISA warrant
application went in which at the top of
the FISA warrant I am told it says
verified call me signed it anyway then
John Solomon's report which of course is
the FBI had their own spreadsheet even
they knew that ninety percent of it was
garbage so then on top of this now we're
seeing just how high up it goes do you
think we get to the question of what did
Obama know when did he know it well the
big meeting occurred just before Comey
went and ambushed then candidate Trump
with the dossier in January 2017 there
was an oval office meeting where Comey
brought up the dossier with a mr. Obama
mr. Biden Susan Rice was there and I
think Brennan was there so they all
discussed the dossier Susan Rice was
there as well
Obama knew about the dossier and the
text messages between struck and page
White House wanted to know about this
look when it came to going after Trump
on the dossier in the Obama
administration it was all hands on deck
and it was orchestrated out of the White
House and I think the big issue is for
the media and investigators why isn't
President Obama been asked any serious
questions about this not one time very
interesting I know sleepy creepy crazy
uncle Joe Biden is going to be asked at
some point tom Fitton great work as
always Judicial Watch